oh
diagonal la leçon bonsoir et bien ce
soir pour présenter cette émission avec
moi stéphane laborde présentateur de
diagonale normalement soeur stéphane 1re
soirée loi donc aujourd'hui on va voir
un thème sacré aux échecs notamment dans
les finales savoir si un fou et bon move
et cette fois c'est plutôt le move est
fou qu'on doit avoir
oui alors dans un premier temps on va
voir le mauvais faux puisque c'est le
plus facile à expliquer c'est me fout en
fait qui va faire double effet avec ses
propres pions c'est à dire qu'il va être
placé en fait sur la même couleur que
ses pions par exemple les noirs ont un
fou de cases blanches et les pions sur
cases blanches problème ça fait double
effet donc on contrôle les mêmes case et
on ne compte plus les cases noires et ça
ça pose un problème notamment contre un
cavalier c'est ce qu'on va voir
aujourd'hui tout à fait donc alors ce
qui est important à noter c'est que
quand on va transposer en finale on va
faire attention effectivement à voir si
on a un fou qui va être bon ou mauvais
pour savoir si effectivement c'est
intéressant de le suivre sur cette
finale ou pas oui alors les finales
effectivement c'est là qu'on voit le
plus la faiblesse du mauvais fou puisque
en finale effectivement il n'y a plus d'
attaque sur le roi donc ça ne sert à
rien de contrôler les cases blanches et
ne roi peut justement s'infiltrer sur
les cases opposé à la couleur du fou
sans avoir peur d'un échec et mat donc
en finale avoir la moitié des cases de
l'échiquier faibles c'est-à-dire toutes
les casses qui ne sont pas contrôlés par
le fou c'est vraiment terrible
alors que les cavaliers lui al'avantage
de pouvoir les sur les cases blanches et
sur les cases noires ce qui lui fait
donc contrôler l'intégralité de
l'échiquier qui est donc un avantage
pour le cavalier alors voir ensuite un
premier exemple ou que tu nous a
concocté qui montre voilà si on voit là
on peut voir son cours m en petit en bas
à droite
voilà donc un exemple où on est en
finale cette fois payé tout de suite et
on voit que les blés noirs dont une
chaîne de pionnat paraître déjà des
signes de pion à l'origine de pions sur
cases blanches qui sont il a notamment
pointé en vert et blanc eux en leurs
pions sur les cases de couleurs opposées
noir et c'est là qu'on voit que le fou
noir de cases blanches film en fait un
double effet et même on peut dire un
effet une quasiment
existants voilà donc ce qu'on va dire
dans cette position c'est que les blancs
contrôle très bien non les noirs contre
le très bien les cases blanches ne pas
ne nous en voyons pas le fou
effectivement peut aller sur toutes les
cases blanches qu'il veut avec la
protection des pions ça y aura pas de
problème le fou peut aller très vite
d'un bout à l'autre de l'échiquier
alors maintenant comment contrer cette
efficacité puisque quand même les noirs
ont un atout certain c'est que peuvent
faire le tour de l'échiquier en quelques
secondes plus tôt en deux trois coups
notre coup de fouet ça y est on est déjà
passé de l'autre côté les bleus en
revanche on n'ont pas cette mobilité
énorme puisque leur cavalier est un
cavalier donc il ne peut se déplacer que
d'une qu'avec eux on va dire de deux
cases à la fois il peut pas aller très
loin très vite cependant le cavalier
peut aller sur les quatre blanche et sur
les cannois c'est là que ça va faire
toute la différence puisqu'on va
s'apercevoir très vite si on regarde
bien cette position donc on va enlever
un petit peu les on va enlever toutes
ces découvertes toutes ses couleurs
et bien regardez ce qu'il se passe
depuis début dans cette position là et
on s'aperçoit rapidement que les noirs
n'ont aucun moyen d'aller déloger le roi
blanc qui est sûre la tsf 6 c'est à dire
que si le roi blanc ne bouge pas les
noirs ne pourront jamais le chasser
alors que l'on rendra lui est
susceptible de subir un échec du
cavalier qui se trouve socas blanche ou
noire
voilà le renoir ou qu'il soit sera
susceptible d'être attaqué donc ici
qu'est ce qu'on peut remarquer il ya
l'option aussi ce qui est faible il est
faible puisque justement il peut être
attaqué par le cavalier donc ici
manoeuvre après voir dû cavaler blanc
cavaliers en f4 ou camions g7 n'est ce
pas oui oui donc qui attaquera le no 6
et qui va finalement le gagner c'est
tout à fait tout à fait important que
dire d'autre dans cette finale
je pense qu'on a à peu près tout dit de
toute façon il ya un principe un grand
principe des finales qui dit pour gagner
il faut deux faiblesses oui donc layar y
aurait on sait que pour attaquer une
chaîne de pions full attack à la base là
la faiblesse des noirs c'est la case au
cices c'est ce qu'ils ont aussi ce qui
est la base de la chaîne de pions donc
pour la niaque une faiblesse donc si les
noirs arrivent à protéger cette
faiblesse avec leurs fous ils vont
probablement arriver à tirer la nulle
quoique ce n'est pas gagné même sac
avait effectivement le cavalier un
avantage de mobilité tellement énorme
c'est à dire que sur une zone localisée
ils peuvent vraiment ennuyer le fou il
peut rendre le fou complètement fou
justement que ce n'est même pas évident
que si les noirs parviennent à défendre
ce pion ils vont tenir la partie en tout
cas dans cet exemple précis c'est au
besoin de jouer et il commence par le
coup très simple le cavalier h5 qui
vient en effet quatre donc très simple
n'oublions pas qu'au échec la base du
jeu c'est de mater et pour cela on a un
moyen très simple et évident qui est
donc la prise de matériel donc car il
est le 4e attaque le pion aux 6 on
profite du fait que le fou soit
actuellement moins de l'action puisqu'il
est sur la tête b3 il ne peut pas
revenir défendre le pion aux six ça
c'est très important
on voit qu'il peut pas être le fief 5 et
ça change un petit peu tout puisque le
pion aux six va être perdu donc les
noirs jouant un coup et jouent par
exemple le fou en d1
c'est une possibilité oui là ils
cherchent bien entendu à revenir sur la
4g 4 ya aucune aucun doute là dessus
qu'ils défendraient bien aussi et
maintenant on joue cavalier trempions de
6 pour alain piaud net de plus et on
voit comme une arme plus les north en
nouvelles faiblesses
quel est le pire en d5 voilà exactement
c'est exactement ça donc là c'est
justement une qu'en dirait une réaction
en chaîne en chaîne d'options ont
d'ailleurs puisqu'on a pris aussi c'est
maintenant c'est l'option des cinq qui
se retrouve affaibli
donc jusqu'à un cavalier va revenir
probablement sur la case f4 il faudra
que les noirs fasse attention aux urnes
dès 5 et donc le protège par exemple par
leurs fonds où le roi mais ça laisse
maintenant le pion aux cinq libre
d'aller à dame
alors c'est exactement ça maintenant
nous sommes dans le cas où il n'y a plus
une seule faiblesse mais il y en a deux
puisqu'on peut considérer on va enlever
les flèches rapidement on considère ici
que le pion aux 6 c'est une faiblesse
pour les noirs le pion aux 5
ceux qui ont vert évidemment c'est une
force pour les blancs puisqu'il n'a pas
d'opposants il est prêt à avancer
donc c'est un pion fort qui compte donc
comme une faiblesse l'autre faiblesse
étant bien entendu ceux qui ont des 5
ça fait donc deux faiblesses pour les
noirs aucune pour les blancs puisque on
voit que le fouillis complètement
incapable d'attaquer en retour la chaîne
d'options des blancs il est incapable
puisqu'il ne peut rester que sont les
cartes blanches c'est là qu'on imagine
que les noirs bien aimé avoir un fou des
cases noires voilà effectivement si
ç'avait été un fou de cases noires
certains bons fous qui n'auraient pas
fait double f avec les pions qui aurait
permis la tacc de toute la structure
blanche et ça aurait tout changé dans
cette position donc ici après quel point
aussi c'est effectivement il ya deux
faiblesses maintenant donc la finale est
logiquement gagnante
on va voir par exemple et noir je fous
g4 ça tend un piège ces attaques le
cavalier aweys un petit piège c'est un
très petit cage effectivement le cas il
y aussi cette emprise
comme on l'avait signalé il va revenir
sur la case f4 d'anglais il est très
efficace puisque il attaque la faiblesse
noir donc c'est très bien parce que ça
va obliger les noirs à mobiliser soit
fou soit le roi sur cette case oui oui
tout à fait ici les noirs ont un gros
problème c'est que le pion passé va
finir par avance et quoi qu'il arrive
c'est à dire que les noirs jouent roy
sait si ce qui serait donc la défense
par le roi ou phase 3 qui serait la
défense par le fou dans les deux cas le
pion aux 5 va avancer
et ici c'est le drame vous pouvez vous
entraîner à jouer cette position on va
regarder quelques cours rapidement ou
mais il n'ya malheureusement aucun
espoir ici de s'en sortir
regardons par exemple qu'houphouët 3 est
maintenant n'avance le pire en ce 6
échecs et cher aux banques
le roi va venir sur la case 8 c'est très
logique et maintenant le coût de plus
simple dans cette position
réfléchissons dit calmement comment
faire pour en fait simplement avancé
espions jusqu'à dame
eh bien on va le mettre sur 15 noir
couleur opposée aux fous c'est très
logique là on voit l envoi la magie de
la position blanche et l'inefficacité
totale des noirs toutes les pièces
blanches sont sur case noire et ça ça
prouve bien que le fou ici est
totalement impuissant à résoudre le
problème s'il y avait eu un cavalier en
d'emplois envisagées se faire d échec
s'il y avait eu un fou taz noir on aura
pu envisager d'attaquer les pions de
faire des échecs aussi ici avec toutes
les pièces noires qui contre
la case blanche c'est pas possible c'est
tout simplement impossible que cette
quel que soit le coût par exemple après
fou aux 4 on met le cavalier sur la case
otis aux menaces claudio cet échec
quel g7 où kbc cet échec suivie de huit
dames qui est imparable
alors bien entendu si les noirs avaient
mille fois en prison ne l'aurais pas
pris de tout temps fois ci on l'aurait
pris d'ailleurs de toute façon il n'y a
aucun problème
la position est facilement gagnante donc
ça c'est un premier exemple on va
revenir sur la position initiale de cet
exemple pour bien montrer qu est ce qui
est mauvais avec ce mauvais fou voilà la
position donc façon en fait l'écho
défensif déjà premier point oui tout à
fait nouveau attaqué la chaîne de points
d'accueil aux cavaliers et à la fraude
défensif parce qu'il peut protéger des
cases noires donc ses propres pions et
offensif puisqu'il peut attaquer les
cases blanches conclut un avantage de
deux possibilités pour les blancs et
étant donné la position telle qu'elle
est avec les pions figé c'est un
avantage certain et blanc ne peuvent pas
perdre et ils ne peuvent que gagner
cette position alors ici pourquoi les
blancs sont probablement gagnant
simplement parce qu'en finale il ya
beaucoup de facteurs d'évaluation il ya
premièrement l'espace et la position des
rois ici on voit que les blancs ont un
droit qui est clairement meilleur que le
roi noir puisqu'il n'est plus avancées
il est déjà en attaque lance ensuite
qu'est ce qui lie à d'autres il ya
justement le mauvais fou ou le bon
cavalier
ici on voit que la structure rupture et
fermés ça
elle est fermée il ya des pions
seulement sur sur un seul côté
l'échiquier les pions sont localisés ils
sont tous regroupés risques et avantages
de cavaliers que c'est un retard il
sortait d'un côté à l'autre alors que le
fou pour contrôler à la fois un côté et
l'autre
avec grâce à sa grande puissance douce
ont fait qu'on règle générale on dit
quand il ya des pions sur les deux ailes
les fous sont plus forts que les
cavaliers
alors il ya des pions sur un seul côté
de l'échiquier local il devient plus
fort alors voyons le deuxième exemple
voyais un deuxième exemple dont qu'on a
on a bien vu celui-là qui est un exemple
pour bâtiment simple un peu plus
compliqué puisque la leur rappelant un
peu moins avancés oui et puis on voit
qui peut pas trop avancer plus puisque
le roi noir et le bloc et là on a deux
îlots de pions on peut dire bondi aux
questions qui sont relativement proches
les uns des autres mais par contre on
voit que les noirs ont toujours le
mauvais fou les noirs ont toujours le
mauvais faut alors l'idée même de plus
en plus mauvais je le serais tenté de
dire puisque vous voyez que il est
complètement bloquée et pour sortir de
ses propres pions il faut un coup de
coup trois ou quatre coups cinq coups et
encore une fois qu'il est sorti ne peut
toujours rien attaqué voyez donc c'est
un four vraiment très très mauvais ouais
ça c'est sûr maintenant la question
c'est est ce que les blancs vont réussir
à passer dans cette position et c'est là
qu'on va regarder tout de suite comment
il faut s'y prendre
le cavalier dans un premier temps via
ces trois là vous voyez que les droits
sont en opposition
donc si le roi noir bouge l'europe va
s'infiltrer dans la position des noirs
on est tout à fait tout à fait donc il
faut jouer le fou on n'a pas vraiment le
choix on va jouer tous mais cette durée
puisqu'on est complètement muselé dans
cette position maintenant le cavalier
vient à 2 oui oui alors c'était
justement que commence tout le problème
le fou va rester là par exemple lancé 8
oui tout à fait et on va mettre le
cabinet en b 4 donc ça c'est la première
amélioration qu'on a fait le foot doit
revenir en 17 ouais pour protéger les
deux pions pour protéger les d'options
mais le problème c'est que là on est les
blancs ne peuvent pas à progresser la
les blancs ont amené leurs cavaliers de
c1 en b 4 voire même de bien en bep cap
puisqu'il était sur la tête bien au
début mais tout à fait voilà maintenant
il va falloir mener le cavalier pour
chasser le roi c'est à dire qu'il va
falloir faire un échec avec le cavalier
puisqu'on voit qu'ici on peut
effectivement plus avancées comme comme
tu l'as dit bon c'est dommage c'est au
noir de jouer
si c'est ton noir de jouer ces gagnants
tout de suite parce que les noirs on
sera obligé de jouer le roi s'est offert
sous peine de perdre un pion et là on
pourrait passer leur blanc et provoqué
ce qu'on appelait d'ailleurs le guen
l'opposition c'est ça tout à fait c'est
le thème de l'opposition c'est à dire
qu'en fait on force le roi à bouger
puisque ici le fou s'il vient à bouger
ne défendra plus un de ses deux pions
n'aura plus qu'à le prendre
et là ça sera complètement gagnant donc
ici le roi noir doit bouger et comme à
chaque fois que les rois sont face à
face le premier qui bouge perd du
terrain puisqu'il donne à l'autre le
moyen de s'engouffrer dans les 10 à 10
donc ici il faut aller chasser le roi de
force
donc on joue cavalier en d3 tout à fait
ça c'est très logique folie noire
continue à jouer leurs fonds pour papa
parce que ce roi f7 on peut jour où
astiz qui dévoile un tout à fait permet
d'avancer sur oracle aura bien
réussissent donc le fou vient en s'est
vite
le cavalier vient maintenant en reste 4
comme prévu ces attaques le pion aux
6-10 c'est là que ça devient assez
critique
ça attaque le pion aux six effectivement
c'est une c'est une réalité
donc ici les blancs les noirs peuvent le
fou 17 ou un seul coup d'ailleurs il y
avait également les coups droits mais
maintenant je cavaliers h5 échec au roi
est donc là les normes pas trop chaud à
ce roi h7 suroît je sais qu'il est
toujours chef d une fourchette cavaliers
six victimes en gagne le fond si l'on
revient la quille m6 qui le fou mais
effectivement ce qu'il faut voir c'est
croire ici s'organise aussi moins 6,8 kg
cet été également guenro f6 eu de
recettes et on mange les pions le roi
vient donc en f7 c'est très logique
maintenant les blancs jorand h6 oui on
sent sinue complètement derrière les
lignes ennemies à z 1000 et noir
l'endroit est monté enrichissent alors
on va falloir maintenant offert un
nouvel échec pour déloger son roi alors
maintenant regardez par exemple déjà se
présente un piège dans cette position si
vous avez bien réviser vos finale de
pions vous voyez quels prêts faut vite
le simple coût cavaliers f6 fait gagner
puisque au coup d'après nous allons
convertir
nous allons charger le fouet finale de
pions et la finale de turin gagnante
pour les blancs la finale de turin
gagnant très simplement puisque nous
sommes sur les quinze critiques du pion
je crois qu'on en avait déjà parlé on a
déjà parlé les fameuses cases critique
le roi plan n'a plus qu'à s'approcher du
pion pour les le manger c'est les quinze
critiques donc là évidemment il a passé
la ligne et demi vous êtes invités à
revoir la leçon sur les finales
d'options ou ici on voit bien que le fou
noir ne peut plus être défendu
donc le bon cavalier va s'échanger
sciemment contre le mauvais fou tout ça
avec l'idée ensuite de gagner avec le
roi donc c'est pour ça que les noirs
sont obligés de jouer le couffo france
et 8 après 3h si si si c'est critique
on ne peut plus bouger droit puisque
neuf points quand même pas trop en
donner
oui si on donne laquelle g7 ça va
devenir vraiment trop dur où donc le
foot doit repartir sur la case ses 8
voilà nous y voilà maintenant objectif
chasser droit de la case f7 oui pour
cela commencer que les noirs n'ont aucun
moyen d'être d'être agressive dans cette
pression d'être offensif il faut penser
manoeuvre pensent les manoeuvres de
cavaliers se dire je vais chasser seront
donc on pourrait jouer cavalier f6
cavaillac cet écart et j'ai cinq échecs
voilà ça c'est une manoeuvre on va
montrer une autre mais bien celle là
parce que ça oblige le fou à aller sur
la case bessette ça ne repousse le fou
ça repousse le fou rire est
effectivement très bien l'autre
manoeuvre possible était de passer par
été efficace kf4 h3 et j'essaie g5 voyez
c'est très joli
c'est très joli on se croyait on se
croirait dans un pentagram antique donc
kalyev si cela les noirs donc s'y joue
le roi avait dansé le roi blanc qui
avance oui
donc il faut jouer le fou pour éviter ça
et en le fonds ne peut aller que cela
casse bessette sous peine d'être pris
oui donc on l'a repoussé le foot mine de
rien il était il a fait le petit chemin
se foule était à 8 milliards us qui ont
presque 1,8 et est obligé de revenir la
maison il en fait il n'a jamais réussi à
passer de l'autre côté des pions mais de
toute façon ça changement puisque nous
comme vous voyez les blancs pratiquement
tout le temps nombre des pièces que sur
caisse noire
c'est à dire que le foot sera
complètement le food et setra
complètement inefficaces ou qu'il soit
très chic et mediastay maintenant très
logique on va chasser l'euro a poussé
vite que proposer d'autres cabines g5
échec au roi dans l'est c'est la clé
moins que les droits est obligé de
laisser du terrain hongrois blanc
j'ouvre roi et suite par exemple trois
fuites donc là bien entendu en it proche
des six on s'approche de la faiblesse
blanc noir qui est le plus réussi ce
mois-là donc ici la menace et 3,6 avec
des seins l'immédiat tandis que si on
arrive à prendre option ici ça va gagné
très facilement
donc il faut que les droits des noirs
empêche cela donc croire c'est trois
sets et maintenant encore problème il
faut faire une menace de cavani il faut
d'abord rendre dans un premier temps on
stabilise la position mais droit sur la
4g 7
ça c'est la première étape maintenant
toutes les pièces censure cases noires
on est tranquille on n'a plus peur du
fou les noirs je vous fous 17 et
maintenant c'est l'heure de la manoeuvre
de cavaliers pour chasser le roi et demi
alors stéphane attention de manoeuvres
difficiles il faut faire attention mais
il faudrait faire un échec sur la case
g8 ou g6 donc je propose encore une fois
d'aller 1h tête en recettes et ensuite
soit en fuite soir 9 6 suivants 1 ce qui
va se passer
alors effectivement le cavalier vie à
venir en achète et ensuite soit et
fluide g 6 soit elle 6 gbit vous voyez
encore un attentat g très très très très
joli donc on y va cavalier h7 et on
rentre dans la position d'un an
maintenant
donc là les noirs ont intérêt à jouer le
coup par exemple sous ie8 qui al'air
d'empêcher au moins la manoeuvre
cavaliers fuite puisque sur cabaye f8
aux joueurs de fourrage 5 et on pourrait
pas faire qu'avec des six sous peine
d'être pris oui mais jamais finale grave
c'est pas grave parce qu'à finale option
serait bien voilà la fin d'adoption est
complètement perdue donc ici on ne peut
plus nous empêcher d'aller en v6 de
toute façon changer vite non plus donc
c'est pareil tous gagnent dans cette
position cavalli et six cavaliers fuite
que les fuites est toujours ici donc là
surtout 17 c on peut prendre le fou
puisque après fou 17 cavaliers prend fou
on va montrer la variante police que
cela va rien à l'option très simple un
ont donc ici on n'a pas peur des changes
et notre bon cavalier contre le mauvais
faux puisqu'on sait que la finale option
est gagnant doit tout de même les prix
en europe on est la preuve c'est que tu
as aussi s'est perdu et est facilement
gagné pour l'honneur aurait fait prendre
position force le roi noir a donné du
terrain est humide après on ramasse le
pion entre 6 et 11 en masse à tous les
autres n'ont pas ça tous les centres
évidemment
de façon impitoyable ici donc flash cinq
fois que c'est un coup et fait peu près
par my faut acheter un qu'on pense qu'on
s'est évadé mais non puisque qu'elle g6
quand même qu'elle décide quand même
puisque ça gagne toujours
voilà faudra que le renoir joue après et
on se rapprochera de loin du pion blanc
et on peut vérifier très facilement que
le pion aussi s'est perdu donc sur four
en justice c'est très simple on est sur
war 17
bonjour roi f6 menaces qui avaient déjà
fuité chèque ou cavaliers f4 qui
attaquent le fouet le pion aux six aussi
alors que les f4 et on donne un peu plus
élevé de toute façon dans cette mission
car les fuites et totalement imparable
ont calé fuite échec chasse le roi et
quel point aussi ce coup d'après ouais
donc ici c'est la fin une fois qu'on a
pris deux pions ont gagné très
facilement
on va leur montrer vite fait comment on
fait pour gagner avec un pion c'est à
dire que par exemple et noir ou rouge et
quatre ont joué cavalier fuite échec
oui l'euro revient à 8 ça y est on a
pris le pion sur foot renvoie prend 7 un
gain facile en finale deux pions on y
revient plus oui maintenant comment on
gagne dans cette position c'est très
simple les noirs jeu n'importe quoi déjà
gagné notre cavalier c'est cet échec et
on gagne le plus raciste ce n'est même
pas la peine puisque la méthode
technique quand on n'en ont pas cessé de
l'avancé quel alléger cet échec le roi
bien où il veut par exemple les fuites
on avance le pion avec un cavalier un
pion contre un fou il c'est très facile
dès qu'on avance le pion c'est fini le
four est de voir se donner contre le
plan ouais ici la menace et aux 7,8 de
huit dames faut absolument prendre
l'option il faut prendre le pion et là
évidemment ça se passe maintenant tout
commentaire il suffit de récupérer ce
fou et de gagner la position donc on va
revenir au début de cette position
rapidement pour résumer tous les points
au début ça a l'air de rien cette finale
on se demande vraiment comment on va
passer ensuite on s'aperçoit que ça va
se passer avec manoeuvre de cavaliers on
va amener notre cavalier sur la case h5
chasser le roi de la cat g7 ont retrouvé
le chemin du cavalier en fait c'est la
difficulté de la position faut trouver
le chemin du cavally et si on était
passé par une diversion pour éviter que
fou noir sorte c'est à dire qu'on avait
fait ce chemin là qu'elle et ses 3 à 2
des 4 d3f 4
et et h5 voilà en effet ce trajet là qui
était un très beau trajet effectivement
très très très long très très technique
une fois qu'on arrive on achetait le roi
noir de partir on commence à gagner du
terrain avec le roi et ensuite quand le
roi noir à l'air stabiliser sur une case
on va faire échec avec lecavalier ont le
pouce on prend du terrain avec le roi on
refait une manoeuvre de cavani on le
repousse et ainsi de suite
et c'est comme ça que ça marche à savoir
qu'à rallier plus croire ça peut
repousser ans et demi car il est plus
trans'arts poussins rangs ennemis
surtout quand il n'y a pas de problème
c'est à dire qu'on le transfert en
finale d'options et gagnant ce qui est
le cas ici
donc ici pourquoi les blancs sont
gagnants simplement parce que les pions
sont sur la même elle est compacte les
noirs dont un mauvais fond et puis le
roi est bien avancé comme voilà
évidemment très le facteur le plus
important c'est sûrement que le roi
blanc a pris plus d espace plus d'
avance donc tout est critique pour les
noirs et effectivement on va finir par
se faire repousser dans cette finale
alors on va voir dernier exemple nous
voir et maintenant nous y voilà
le dernier exemple cessé une partie
qu'on a déjà vu qu'on a vu donc entre
alexandra les kin le fameux champions du
monde russes au franco russe
franco-russe et donc y est qu'il y avait
un grand maître très fort de l'époque
aussi oui j'adore l'équipe du champion
du monde avant là un petit peu avant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
c'était en 36 ou 37 si mes souvenirs
sont bons et contrecarre à blanca on va
tout à fait tout à fait stéphane donc
ici c'est la position que vous pouvez
revoir si vous voyez la partie commenté
par jean luc chavanon et bertrand guyard
la semaine dernière c'est donc
l'émission du lundi 17 au lundi 17
juillet ils ont ils sont passés sur
cette position ils sont commentés la
partie est ici qu'est ce qu'on voit si
on revient un petit peu c'est un segment
de partie on voit que lecavalier et en
os 5 et que le fourreau noir il est en a
six non il est mauvais il est mauvais
puisqu'il est sur la même couleur que
les pions vous voyez à vide et il est
vraiment sur quatre blanche c'est un fou
casse blanche donc
foutaise manche avec des pions de cartes
blanches ça va pas et les noirs les
blancs ont une très forte gaz en simple
à cazaux 5 qui est où ils ont installé
un cavalier qui est ce qu'on appelle
indélogeable alors pour moi souvent on
dit monstres humains et surtout
indélogeable parce qu'on ne peut pas le
déloger tout à fait on ne peut pas le
déloger simplement parce que les pions
ne revienne pas en arrière il est
monstrueux est indélogeable voilà il est
il est vraiment trop gros on voit que
l'option des cinq ne peut pas revenir en
d6 l'option f5 ne peut pas revenir en m6
parce que les gens ne reviennent pas en
arrière donc ici le kode5 et monstreux
indélogeable les tours blanches sont
plus actives oui et leurs problèmes des
noirs dans cette position c'est que ils
ne savent pas quoi faire avec leur fout
pas six ce x 6 ne peut absolument rien
attaquer ouais il est complètement
inerte inerte donc ici il ya une
proposition une proposition qui a été
faite par bertrand guyard et par
jean-luc chavanon c'était de jouer le
tour s'est vite temps s'est vite qu'ils
échangent les tours pour contrecarrer la
puissance sur la tour nos colonnes c'est
puisque les valeurs menacées de mon
jouet tour c'est cette suite aux ossètes
et enfin la deuxième tour en sept
employés roce
voilà ça je vous invite à revoir la
partie pour voir comment allaient keane
a profité des deux tours doublé sur la
colonne c'est ouais mais ici c'est une
tentative de contrecarrer ces fameuses
tours doublé avec tours s'est vite alors
une solution simple ce n'est pas la
seule il ya beaucoup de solutions dans 7
pays si on peut par exemple le tour ces
sept on peut jouer pour ces sites ont
peu bougé le cavaliere peut amener le
roi au centre mais une solution très
simple
par contre c'est de jouer tu reprends
toi pour prendre tôt tourcoing tours
tourcoing tours donc vous prend vous
prend et là donc on à échanger toutes
les tours et on est arrivé dans notre
modèle économique
ouais puisque là
donc les bleus ont clairement le bon
cavalier contre mûri fou on se retrouve
dans le même schéma que tout à l'heure
le plus d'options
oui on voit bien que les pions noirs
sont fixés socas blanche ils sont pas ne
peuvent pas trop avancé en plus et ils
sont quasiment bloquées alors que les
pions blancs soient en majorité sur
cases noires donc avec un cavalier qui
donc est plus fort que le fou le
cavalier beaucoup plus fort que fou pour
une raison simple c'est qu'il peut aller
sur le casque branché sur le capteur il
est très mobile dans le brouillard gagne
tout de suite un peu en arrière c'est
qu'elle est le premier la première chose
à faire dans ce genre de finale stéphane
peut-être ça peut être ça peut être
d'activer le roi oui ça peut être aussi
ici de viser les faiblesses tweet suite
on voit qu'il ya deux faiblesses visible
dans l'eau qu'un noir c'est le pion aux
6 et le pion à 4 voilà donc
éventuellement qui a aidé trois actes et
ses cinq arrières de gagner un pur d'un
salaire de guînes à plomb d'ailleurs sa
guise un pion mais le geste technique ce
n'est pas ça puisque ça c'est de la
tactique
ces attaques c'est de la tactique donc
ce n'est pas joli le geste technique
c'est le roi qui monte
voilà donc ça hervé leroy ça c'est
vraiment le geste le plus technique
bref de l'est normalement les noirs font
pareil trentenaire qui savent pas trop
quoi faire avec leur foi ci se développe
pas je veux réussir être déjà il faut
pas se leurrer recette puisque le
cavadee commence déjà à les bloquer ils
ont un problème est effectivement c'est
que seront les fuites bon il y aura
toujours cet ennui tactique et détroit
qui essaient 5 qui sera plus graves
puissent comprendre à qui on bosse ici
avec échec donc ici ils peuvent jouer un
coup comme x 6 c'est une possibilité
pour éviter que le cabinet ne vienne
trop mes ennuis
oui maintenant le roi 0-1 et maintenant
ça va être la montée fatale
jusque là prise de ce pion est séparable
des fuites radioactives le roi c'est
vrai que c'est quand même recette
en c3 c3 nous y voilà on peut très bien
envisager ce coup fourré fin oui c'est
une diversion mais on s'en fout
puisqu'on est le pion bien entendu sur
case noire oui comme ça il y aura plus
de problème prochain coup on peut très
bien envisager d'où le coup f3 et f4 il
maintenant c'est fini puisque on va
jouer le roi en d4
ouais l'ailé nord peuvent faire un
mauvais signe pour protéger le pion
alors foutez 5 continue son bon droit en
d4 tac le fouet le pire en il faut
emmener le alors faut surtout pas mettre
le fou en lice du cavalier puisque la
finale l'option est encore une fois
perdant 2 vite et fort c est ici
maintenant c'est très simple qu'est-ce
qu'on fait une fois qu'on a bien amené
le roi où il fallait dans nos petits
vieux cavaliers mais voilà il faut faire
jouer la deuxième classe tout simplement
donc maintenance et leurs cavaliers
detroit suivie par kbc 5 qui avait
procuré quatre ans franck louvier trois
essais gagnant et c'est terminé mais les
options sont trop forts ils vont faire
diversion par une colle et noir vont
s'occuper de ses deux pions on va manger
tous les autres pions un peu à côté
voire même les options pourraient eux
tous les pions que de gagner tout seul
donc ici une fois de plus très simple on
amène le roi et on gagne en fait pour
résumer la situation c'est le secteur
donc ça c'est général en finale
on le voit que c'est valable aussi
d'intégrer dans les finales avec des
mauvais fou c'est que effectivement le
roi devient une pièce prépondérante en
finale alors je pense qu'on va s'arrêter
là en fait pour cette leçon on va
résumer tout ce qui s'est passé c'est à
dire comment gagner en fait qu'est-ce
qui fait que la pression est gagnante
qu'est ce qui fait que le faux est
mauvais première chose première chose
pour qu'ils refusent sont mauvais c'est
qu'il est soi même coup leur conception
ça c'est indispensable c'est très
important le fou et donc sur la couleur
sépia
deuxième chose les pions sont bloqués
puisque évidemment s'ils sont sur la
même couleur que le fou et qui peuvent
avancer le seront plus au coup d'après
donc ça c'est clair il faut que les
prisons soient bloquées sur les routes
où la pole font ensuite il faut qu'on
ait un cavalier avec une caste forte à
la casse forte étant optionnel il faut
qu'on ait un cavalier il faut que les
pions soit bloquée et ce qui fait gagner
c'est donc d'amener le roi vert la
faiblesse et demi c'est d'amener le roi
vert le premier pion qu'on peut attaquer
n'est-ce pas tout à fait tout à fait
tout à fait nous y voilà donc voilà ça
c'est le saas et le plan devient ici on
a vu trois exemples où on amène le roi
près du pion cible ensuite c'est une
manoeuvre de cavaliers qui nous permet
de chasser les pièces et demi donc et
aussi vous rappeler c'est le pion à pas
la base de la chaîne de pions la base de
la chaîne de pions donc effectivement en
général c'est une combinaison de
facteurs qui gagne c'est à dire le roi
qui est bien avancée c'est à dire qu'on
a un droit plus actifs le fou adverse
est mauvais les lecavalier fait des
manoeuvres et ensuite on ramasse un
premier pion et là c'est fini puisque on
a deux faiblesses c'est à dire qu'il ya
encore d'autres pions qui sont faibles
on a un pion de passer à annoncer et ses
gagnants alors je pense que la
difficulté c'est pas de gagner ces
finales enfin entraînez-vous quand même
vous pouvez reprendre ses positions là
et vous entraîner à les gagner contre
votre maman ou compteur soit dans
l'aisne compte pour tenter la même
séance est important d'essayer de gagner
final tout seul évite d'ailleurs
oui c'est lizeroux les plus rapides
exactement essayer aussi de la défendre
d'ailleurs ce jeu contre vous même comme
ça ça vous mettra dans les deux
situations et c'est énervant c'est plus
une erreur de forme
donc voila mais alors le plus important
donc une fois vous saurez bien gagner ça
puisque c'est la base
comme vous avez pu apprendre les finales
de pions que maintenant vous savez quand
elles sont gagnantes ou ne le sont pas
c'est très important et dans la leçon de
la semaine prochaine on verra des
transpositions de position normale vers
des positions avec un mauvais coup
contre un bon cavalier
ce sera le thème de la prochaine leçon
stéphane exactement que se donne
rendez vous à la prochaine leçon donc ça
sera le lundi 31 normalement si tout va
bien
eh bien merci d'avoir suivi cette
émission donc c'était fade laborde merci
de rien et donc à la semaine prochaine
et très bonne soirée
oh